We all have seen raisins swelling up when
kept in water for some time.
Any idea how this magic works?
Well, it is simply the process of osmosis
which results in the swelling of these resins!
You heard me right.
It is Osmosis process due to which the water
from the surrounding medium enters the cells
of raisins helping them to swell.
Can we define osmosis once?
It is simply defined as the process in which
water moves from higher water concentration
to lower water concentration through a semi
permeable membrane.
An interesting thing to know about osmosis
is that the movement of water is affected
by the amount of a substances dissolved in it!
And what does this mean exactly?
Let us conduct an experiment to understand it better.
Let us take three plates or containers with
salt solutions of different concentration
in each.
Let us add a few red blood cells that is RBCs in each.
After a while we clearly notice that the first
set has cells which are shrinked.
The second set has cells that are just the
same while the third set has cells which are
swollen or bulged.
Any idea why this happened?
Let us understand this.
In the first case, the water content in the
surrounding solution was less as compared
to the cells placed in it.
In other words, the salt content of the solution
is more and therefore this solution is a concentrated
one.
That is the reason why the water molecules
moved from inside the cells to the outside
solution as the concentration of water was
higher within the cells.
Hence the cells started shrinking.
This kind of a solution is called as a HYPERTONIC
solution.
That is the solution with higher salt concentration.
Now let’s have a look at the second case.
Here, the level of salt and water seems to
be the same on either side of the cell membranes.
That is both, within and outside the cell.
Therefore there was a balance in the movement
of water.
What do we understand by this?
It means that the movement of water was the
same in either directions.
As a result, the size of the cell did not change.
It remained the same!
Do you know what such a solution is called as?
It is called an ISOTONIC solution.
The two solutions are isotonic when the concentration
of water is same on either sides of the semi
permeable membrane!
Now let us focus on this third set.
The cells in this case are surrounded by a
dilute solution that is by higher water concentration.
The salt dissolved is less and the water content
is higher.
Therefore, water molecules move inside the
cells and hence the cells got swollen.
Such a solution is called as a HYPOTONIC solution.
In other words, solution with a higher water
concentration compared to the other.
This is how various solutions and their different
concentrations help cells to sustain pressure
and to survive.
Movement of molecules across the plasma membrane
is also influenced by this simple process
of osmosis!